[Applause]
i think grabbing the tie is illegal
isn't it that's the power to i almost
took it right over just like that
my head would have gone with it yeah let
me ask you something i'm watching that
tape of you
and uh and i'm realizing that your your
trademark at this point really is
flipping people the bird that has become
your trademark is that not true it is
somewhat of a trademark
you do it to your fans and they it's
their way of saluting you
more so of a salute now if i did it to
them i mean it's kind of how you direct
it like if you were an opponent and i
directed that at you you would know that
i'm not saluting you i'd be saying right
exactly what that says
right right i've done something there's
actually a little method to the matter
if i if i make my entrance the first one
is this right when the match is over
then the middle finger goes up so it's
all timing so you've thought a lot about
this oh yeah now
if you told me this
if you told me there's a whole if you
told me a couple years ago that i'd make
11 flipping people off and drinking beer
well i'd probably said you're crazy but
i seem to have been able to do that but
what's weird for you is that
your fans you'd be driving along and you
must have fans
all the time flipping you the bird right
again it's all in the delivery because
i'd be riding down the highway and then
someone
you know some ecstatic fans that come up
come down the highway and they'll be
giving you the
the business either oh they're stone
cold fans then every now and then you
get the one who of course is not cool
with the things i do and you get the
you just got to read the lips a little
bit which i become somewhat of an expert
act
and you know that if they're basically
not a stone cold fan they mean that
to me right right yeah that's when
you're avoiding that because
i think a lot of your fans have been
mistaking me for you and uh
you know what i believe there's a
similarity
well you got to get a similar build i
know it said that coming up
yeah i don't know people don't know
people don't know but if i
if i strip to the waist you people would
not be able to tell us apart double
body double yeah well you did the thing
the other day about two nights ago you
flipped out of your chair and landed
back here and i said man
what an athlete because last time
i mean i just slipped last time i was
here
i was talking about you getting the
runner's legs all that right you did the
flip thing
right bam you're on the weights you're
in so you think oh it's a little bit
he only needs a little bit of work and i
could become one of the most feared
wrestlers of all time i don't know about
feared
you're a great trash talker one of the
best and this is a quote of yours
because you you're very imaginative i'd
like to open up a can of whoop ass and
serve a cup of shut the hell up
but it really didn't take a whole lot of
imagination a lot of people sit there
saying man how do you come up with all
this stuff
and when you grow up in south texas you
hear that every day tell my mom used to
tell me that in the morning she would
your mom would serve you a cup of shut
the hell up with authority
worth authority oh yeah i'll have a
double decaf please don't hurt me
that's my own uh and so uh work on that
let's talk about jessie the body ventura
because you guys have an event coming up
right sunday biggest second biggest pay
view of the year summerslam yeah
summerslam that's this we're that we're
going to plug that in that's this sunday
night right
um he's going to be refereeing what is
your opinion of the man
i mean are you into politics do you
think he's a good governor do you
well i'm really not into politics
whatsoever but years ago when he needs
to be a commentator well
a wrestler also always enjoyed listening
to his interviews guys got a real good
voice
a very articulate very good delivery and
he's very intelligent too so he's
basically taking that same uh
way to speak and put in front of people
and got into politics and you know he's
i don't know all the issues the ins and
outs of politics i'm not into that but
the guy kind of captures you when he
speaks
but as far as it always liked you know
his work in the ring you know not so
much he wasn't that fancy
uh you know he was outlandish i like
that but going into summerslam you know
he's going to be the referee
laying down the law or whatever you know
basically i do what i want when i want
in the world wrestling federation and
i don't expect anything to happen with
jesse the body of interior let's say for
example
what if he does get in your face the
governor jesse ventura what if he's
what if he starts to get in your face
about something i'll give him that
salute we were talking about earlier
[Applause]
i like the way you said that the can of
whoop ass could come into effect
there's a whole arsenal of things that
could come into play i get the whole
menu there but yeah i don't think he
i don't know what to think cause you
know it's gonna be a big event you could
take the man though in a fight couldn't
you
like that really yeah and yeah i'm not
saying that's pretty much the bottom
line
right right respect for him back then
still got some respect for him now what
he does but you don't like the fact that
he's now a he's now a public servant
he's a governor i'm just you know you
can't yards
yeah really yeah i'm not i'm not so much
worried about him to be the bodyguards i
was probably standing ringside
right well i respect the guy and
everything like that but no when he
steps in the into the ring of the know
war russian federation now he's stepping
into my office
and then that's when uh i'm in charge
and he'll find that out
oh he will yeah because he's talking all
that trash right now he's going to do
just fine but
he'll know oh yes you will
i don't like it when you look at me that
way when you're mad at someone else it's
really scary to be sitting here right
there no stop it just
i don't want you to get me that dropkick
we're talking about all right cause i
now i i know that you're a big uh you're
a beer aficionado
is that true you like your beer you've
incorporated into your
into your character i haven't known to
sip an occasional beverage
you like the beer you like oh yeah i dig
beer we had
we uh we brought you some beer here
because i thought we'd want to meet him
but you were you guys made him not feel
right at all yeah i wanted you to feel
comfortable here i wanted you to drink a
lot and then i would beat you senseless
uh
i could fight pretty good drunk yeah oh
okay i got that going for me too
no good either way multi-faceted over
here so so i
and i thought maybe you could show us
because you're very imaginative and
colorful in the way that you drink beer
maybe you could demonstrate for andy and
i
by the way
[Applause]
yeah yeah all right let's go what do we
do you open it up
you're not opening that beer don't you
um yeah i do i will need a strawberry
there you go okay just all right now
wait show us what to do
well of course you got to crash them
together what do you mean someone could
get hurt
no he's good take a firm hold on a
little bit yeah about like that
like that and you go like what
i have my own method yeah they're gonna
do the sterile code one-on-one on beer
all right what do you do you slam it
again and this time now i bought a slam
we've already done that so now we're
just drinking
okay and you just get a little different
you just literally just pour it into
your mouth
yeah you got swell a few times now
you're not going to sit over there with
us right
all
right
[Music]
now what's the next one well you're
drinking beer come on now
you impressed me with the first one now
anybody can get lucky
you don't have to twist his arms
right in the center of the ring well
it's easy to drink beer for the first
row
but you got to drink beer for the last
row right that's why you got to get that
extension in there with your arm
and if you stand up it's easier for the
beer to go down so we stand there you'd
be standing up
all right
[Applause]
there you go how high
how do you feel no how do you feel
how do you feel
you all right yeah you ready for the
salute yeah
are you what's the salute
middle fingers oh we're not gonna oh
how are you doing over here i'm doing it
all right here we go
[Applause]
did he just do this job on the side or
what's the deal there he's got a problem
i'll probably run into you at the next
let me make sure i mention this um i'm
standing up so that everything drains
uh you're gonna be just fine yeah i'm
fine uh summerslam airs sunday night
august 22nd on pay-per-view stone cold
steve us it's been great having you
we're gonna take a quick break
[Applause]